und wieder eine neue studio plötzlich
kommt jetzt nämlich fahrt ins thema
französische fachleute haben jetzt jede
menge daten und fallstudien aus der
vergangenheit noch einmal genauer ins
visier genommen in dem 365 seiten
starken bericht geht es vor allem um
fälle die andere fachleute bereits als
ungeklärt eingestuft hatten
was also hat es mit den mysteriösen
ufo-sichtungen weltweit auf sich klicks
um science reviews gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen die ganze welt im
ufo fieber genauer gesagt geht es ja um
die sogenannten apps also die nicht
identifizierten luft und raumfahrt
phänomene
doch nicht nur fachleute in den usa
haben sich dem thema angenommen wir
hatten ja bei klicksafe lucia
ausführlich darüber berichtet einen rund
365 seiten starker bericht zum thema
kommt von fachleuten und dem astronauten
john fraser clair aus frankreich die
vorstände hatten acht jahre lang daten
und fallstudien noch einmal genauer ins
visier genommen sie alle sind teil der
sogenannten sigma 2 kommission die vor
einigen jahren aus einer der
angesehensten forschungsgesellschaften
der luft und raumfahrt hervorgegangen
ist die französische la source
astronautik astronautik de france dazu
einer der beteiligten ingenieure lücke
die nie unser ziel ist es beobachtungen
die gemacht wurden aus einem technischen
und wissenschaftlichen standpunkt zu
betrachten
bei der analyse ging es um vorfälle die
zu verschiedenen zeiten und in
verschiedenen geographischen gebieten
beobachtet worden waren
das forschungsteam der aktuellen studie
beschränkte sich dabei auf den zeitraum
von 1950 bis heute die forschungsgruppe
gibt es bereits seit dem jahr 2008
damals war sie unter dem namen pan sigma
gegründet worden das ziel die
untersuchung der sogenannten pan die
abkürzung für unidentifizierte phänomene
im luftraum auf französisch phänomen
alles was von identität seit acht jahren
2013 aber konzentriert sich sigma 2 vor
allem auf jene unfälle die von anderen
fachleuten als ungeklärt eingestuft
worden waren vor elf jahren 2010 gab es
schon einmal einen bericht dieser
forschungsgruppe zu diesem thema dabei
hatten
sich die fachleute auf den so genannten
ko meter bericht aus dem jahr 1999
berufen
damals hatten sich geheimdienste und das
französische militär mit dem ufer thema
auseinandergesetzt das sieht man zwei
teams kamen damals zu dem fazit das
zitat ufos real und wahrscheinlich
außerirdischen ursprungs sind
jetzt also der zweite bericht der nach
aussage der beteiligten autorinnen
autoren keineswegs zitat ein einfacher
kommentar zu anderswo bereits
durchgeführten studien sei
zu welchen ergebnissen ist das
forschungsteam gekommen sind ufos real
und möglicherweise sogar außerirdischen
ursprungs
fest steht schon seit jahrzehnten
beschäftigt sich die ganze welt mit dem
thema ende des vergangenen monats juni
2021 dann ließen die usa die bombe
platzen
das us verteidigungsministerium und die
us geheimdienste hatten den lang
ersehnten bericht zum thema
veröffentlicht demnach ist es denkbar
dass es sich bei 143 sichtungen von
unbekannten flugobjekten kurzum
flugobjekte einer außerirdischen
zivilisation handel zumindest kann dies
trotz einer intensiven untersuchung
nicht ausgeschlossen werden 18 dieser
beobachtung sind demnach sogar komplett
unerklärlich mittlerweile redet die
fachwelt übrigens nicht mehr offiziell
von ufos sondern von ups das steht für
an identifizieren
auf deutsch nicht identifizierte luft
phänomene
gerätselt wird über verschiedene videos
aus den vergangenen jahren auf vielen
von ihnen sind flugobjekte zu sehen die
sich wirklich seltsam verhalten sehr
seltsam so wie wir es auf der erde sonst
nicht kennen so zum beispiel im jahr
2004 damals waren flugobjekte mehrere
wochen über dem pazifik unterwegs die
fachleute nicht einordnen konnten dann
hatte man sich entschieden zwei us
kampfpiloten loszuschicken um die sache
ein für allemal aufzuklären die beiden
piloten berichteten wirklich
erstaunliches demnach hatten sie ein
mysteriöses objekt etwa 15 meter
oberhalb der wasseroberfläche daraus dem
pazifik aufgespürt es sei nicht nur rund
13 meter lang sondern habe sich auch in
einer unvorstellbaren geschwindigkeit
fortbewegt allerdings erst als die
piloten sich dem weiter näherten
dazu hatte einer der piloten in einem
interview mit der times gesagt es
beschleunigte sich wie nichts was ich
jemals gesehen habe
die piloten seien dann weiter zu ihrem
treffpunkt geflogen etwa hundert
kilometer entfernt dort entdeckten sie
das objekt dann wieder
demnach muss dieses diese strecke in
sehr kurzer zeit zurückgelegt haben auch
der ehemalige navy pilot david fray will
vor einigen jahren mysteriöse
beobachtungen gemacht haben er hatte in
einem interview das folgende berichtet
als ich ihm nahe kam hat es schnell
richtung süden beschleunigt und ist in
weniger als zwei sekunden verschwunden
die bewegung des objekts beschreibt er
als zitat extrem abrupt die schnelle
bewegung habe ihn an einem
tischtennisball erinnert der zitat von
einer wand abprallt 2015 ereignete sich
wohl ein ähnlicher vorfall hier wird man
zwei piloten die ebenfalls flugobjekte
entdeckt hatten die sich nicht eindeutig
identifizieren ließen in der aufnahme
hört man die männer ganz erstaunt rufen
es ist eine ganze flotte ihren
erzählungen zufolge waren die objekte in
gigantischer geschwindigkeit unterwegs
und rotierten über die wasseroberfläche
in us-medien berichteten die
kampfpiloten dass sie während eines
trainings einsatzes auf dem
flugzeugträger ziel der roosevelt immer
wieder unbekannte flugobjekte über der
amerikanischen ostküste gesichtet haben
wollen jeden tag seien die objekte in
der luft gewesen und das über einen sehr
langen zeitraum von bis zu zwölf stunden
auch abgaswolken hatten die ufos demnach
nicht hinter sich hergezogen das alles
spricht nach ansicht der piloten ganz
klar dafür dass menschen nicht dahinter
stecken können alleine die rasante
beschleunigung die piloten sprechen von
einer hyper geschwindigkeit sei dafür
viel so unvermittelt passiert und das in
einem raschen wechsel mit abrupten stopp
handelt es sich etwa um neue
technologien um waffensysteme aus china
oder russland oder tatsächlich um
raumschiffe oder sonden von
außerirdischen oder sind diese seltsamen
erscheinungen am himmel auf das wetter
meteo schauer oder flugzeug tests
zurückzuführen auch technische fehler so
etwas wie linsen reflektionen oder eine
überlastung der piloten kommt in frage
genau das sind die fragen die gerade
über allem stehen fest steht selbst
renommierte fachleute schließen
mittlerweile nicht mehr aus dass diese
mysteriösen flugobjekte von
außerirdischen spezies sein können genau
das bestätigt jetzt auch der berichte
sigma zwei teams die ufo fachleute
hatten für ihre analyse die
ähnlichkeiten zwischen verschiedenen
fällen verglichen und diese dann mit
dem phänomen abgeglichen das
forschungsteam betont dass es sich bei
dieser arbeit nicht um einen einfachen
kommentar zu bereits durchgeführten
studien handelt sondern um eine eigene
ausarbeitung die fachleute wollen mit
ihrem bericht daten und fakten auf den
tisch legen die beurteilung und
schlussfolgerungen dieser erkenntnisse
über las man aber lieber den lesern und
leserinnen nach vorne preschen das
forschungsteam dabei nicht ganz im
gegenteil vieles bleibt er vage und nur
für wenige beobachtung bei denen die
datenlage ausreichend ist werden die
fachleute konkret ein beispiel dafür die
sogenannte kuga fall dabei geht es um
die beobachtung die zwei
besatzungsmitglieder an bord eines
chilenischen marine hubschrauber im
november 2014 gemacht hatten über den
hafen von san antonio und könnte hatten
sie mit einer hochauflösenden
infrarotkamera ein mysteriöses objekt
gesichtet dieses flog nach angaben der
crew mit einer konstanten
geschwindigkeit vor dem hubschrauber
mehr als zehn minuten konnte das objekt
beobachtet werden doch die flugsicherung
war nicht in der lage ist auf dem radar
zu erkennen auch der versuch mit dem
objekt über funk zu kommunizieren schlug
fehl
nach den berichten der crew von damals
schien das ufo sogar zwei mal
unbekanntes gas oder rauch auszustoßen
seitdem wurde viel über diese
beobachtung spekuliert um was könnte es
sich wirklich gehandelt haben ein
chilenischer experte hatte das so
eingeordnet sie waren hoch qualifizierte
fachleute mit langjähriger erfahrung und
waren sich absolut sicher dass sie sich
nicht erklären konnten was sie sagen das
sieht mal zwei team hatte sich in seiner
ausführlichen analyse auch diesen fall
genauer angesehen und kommt nach der
analyse von rada und infrarot daten zu
einem klaren ergebnis beim kuba fall
handelt es sich um einen airbus a340
demnach steckt also zumindest bei diesem
fall kein raumschiff eine außerirdische
spezies oder ähnliches dahinter auch der
fall der rb 47 wurde vom sigma 2
forschungsteam genauer ins visier noch
mal ein flugzeug der us luftwaffe hatte
im sommer 1957 ein absolut mysteriöses
objekt gesichtet 1300 kilometer weit war
dem flugzeug ein zitat großes helles
licht gefolgt dass funkwellen
ausgesendet hatte dazu heißt es in dem
aktuellen bericht aus frankreich das
objekt wurde von der besatzung visuell
beobachtet von bodenradar vom rb 47
radar und von hoch entwickelter elektr
chronischer kriegsführung ausrüstung die
sich an bord des flugzeugs befanden
erkannt demnach handelt es sich auch
dabei um ein zitat interessanten fall da
er so gut dokumentiert seit detailliert
daten aber fehlen und so bleibt
weiterhin offen um welche art von
flugobjekte es sich damals wohl
gehandelt hat und es gibt weitere
ungelöste fälle zu den fans schreibt das
forschungsteam die folgende
zusammenfassung diese phänomene offenbar
je nach fall unterschiedliche
eigenschaften und üben teilweise
mechanische einwirkung auf den boden aus
die mit der bekannten physik nicht
erklärbar sind obwohl natürlich
fälschung existieren ist die realität
dieser phänomene unbestreitbar ob es
sich um eine natürliche oder künstliche
herkunft handelt ist noch immer eine
offene frage je nach fall liegt das an
den noch wenig verstandenen
atmosphärischen ionosphäre ischen und
elektromagnetischen phänomen aber auch
das unvorhersehbare elektromagnetische
und insbesondere kinematische verhalten
dieser phänomene stellt uns noch immer
vor große rätsel dieses seltsame
verhalten widerspricht den gesetzen der
physik insbesondere der mechanik das
erschwert zudem auch unsere arbeit denn
es ist fast unmöglich systematische
aufzeichnungen dazu anzufertigen
in einigen fällen aber scheint es wohl
nahe zu liegen das sogenannte
kugelblitze mit ufo verwechselt wurden
gemeint sind damit eine spezielle form
von blitzen die nur eine sehr kurze
lebensdauer von nur wenigen sekunden
haben beim zerfall eines solchen blitz
ist kann eine art perlenschnur von
kleinen leuchtenden kugeln entstehen
doch das ist alles andere als einfach
nachzuweisen kugelblitze sind somit für
die wissenschaft deswegen auch ein fast
so großes rätsel wie ufos selbst mehr
zum amerikanischen bericht gibt es ihr
ufo videos zeigen echte flugobjekte sagt
das pentagon anklicken anschauen also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht ganz einfach mit dem abo button
unter jedem video das ist kostenlos und
macht schlau bis dann bleibt dran